Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Bonsoir.
Je m’appelle Christophe Bernard.
Je suis directeur de recherche à l’Inserm,
à l’Institut de neurosciences
des systèmes,
et je travaille sur les
mécanismes de l’épilepsie.
Aujourd’hui, je voudrais
vous emmener faire un voyage
au-delà des frontières
de la médecine du cerveau.
Ah ! Veuillez m’excuser.
C’est mon médecin qui me dit que,
au vu de mes dernières analyses,
il prédit que je vais développer
la maladie d’Alzheimer d’ici dix ans.
Ça c’est une prédiction
dont je me serais bien passé.
Ça continue.
Il m’indique aussi qu’il existe un
traitement personnalisé et préventif
qui va empêcher la maladie de se produire.
Ouf !
Évidemment, ça,
c’est de la science-fiction,
mais c’est ce que veut réaliser
la médecine du futur.
Et cette médecine du futur, elle a un nom.
C’est la médecine « 3P ».
Ces trois P sont : P de Personnalisé,
P de Prédictif,
et P de Préventif.
Pourquoi on a besoin
d’une telle médecine ?
Le cerveau, c’est un peu
comme une voiture.
Au cours du temps, les pièces s'usent.
Pour la voiture, ça peut conduire à des
défauts, un mauvais fonctionnement.
Dans le cerveau, c'est la même chose.
Au fur et à mesure
que le cerveau vieillit,
on a de plus en plus de risques
de développer des maladies du cerveau.
Alors on pourrait se dire :
« Pourquoi ?
Si la nature était bien faite,
on vieillirait en bonne santé. »
Là, il se trouve que comme l’espérance
de vie de l’humanité ne cesse d’augmenter,
on vit de plus en plus vieux
et il y a de plus en plus de personnes
atteintes de maladies du cerveau.
Et elles sont nombreuses :
les épilepsies, la maladie de Parkinson,
la maladie d’Alzheimer et bien d’autres.
Pourquoi on ne vieillit pas
en bonne santé ?
Pourquoi le cerveau ne vieillit-il pas
sans développer des pathologies ?
Pour illustrer de façon possible
la réponse à cette question,
Je vais vous montrer
une vieille photo de famille.
Au paléolithique,
il y a environ 3,3 millions d’années,
l’espérance de vie était de 22 à 33 ans.
Cette espérance de vie n’a pas
changé jusqu’au Moyen-Âge.
C'est resté de 22 à 33 ans.
Ça veut dire quoi ?
Ça veut dire que,
au cours des millénaires,
l’évolution s’est faite, et la sélection
s’est faite, de telle sorte que
nous soyons optimisés
pour la reproduction,
pour la forme physique et pour
nos capacités entre 22 et 33 ans.
Il n’y avait pas besoin
de sélectionner des gènes
qui nous permettent
de vieillir en bonne santé,
de faire en sorte que le cerveau
ne développe pas de maladies
parce que c’était
un nombre très petit d’individus
qui atteignaient l'âge de 60 ans.
Ce patrimoine génétique, on en a hérité,
on ne peut pas le changer.
C’est pour ça qu’il faut
une médecine adaptée
pour répondre au besoin de l’augmentation
du nombre de maladies du cerveau.
C'est un enjeu de santé publique majeur.
Maintenant on peut se demander
pourquoi et comment,
d’où ça vient
et pourquoi il faut
une approche personnalisée.
Le fonds génétique, comme vous le savez,
le patrimoine génétique,
Il est personnel.
Votre patrimoine génétique
est différent du mien.
Il est différent de celui de vos voisins.
On en a tous un différent.
Et vous savez aussi que nous
que nous avons des gènes à risque
de développer des pathologies.
Les cancers, mais aussi
les maladies du cerveau.
Par exemple, dans la population,
2% de cette population porte
une mutation sur un gène.
Les porteurs de cette mutation
ont dix fois plus de chances
de développer la maladie d’Alzheimer.
Ça, ça vous montre que
le patrimoine génétique de chacun
joue un rôle fondamental sur l’expression,
la manifestation des maladies du cerveau.
Et ça, ça justifie
une approche personnalisée.
Mais les gènes n’expliquent pas tout,
l’environnement joue un rôle
aussi très important.
La façon dont on mène sa vie,
ce que l’on mange,
selon qu’on boit de l’alcool,
qu’on fume, qu’on fasse du sport,
ou qu’on subisse des stress intenses
dans l’environnement du travail
vont aussi jouer un rôle important
sur le risque de développer
des maladies du cerveau.
Et comme on a des expériences de vie
qui sont uniques, qui sont personnelles,
il faut d’autant plus avoir
une approche personnalisée
qui tienne compte
du fonds génétique unique
et des expériences uniques
menées par chaque personne.
Donc ça, ça vous explique pourquoi on a
besoin d’une médecine personnalisée.
Maintenant, pourquoi
doit-elle être prédictive ?
Bah déjà, tout simplement
parce que si notre fond génétique
fait que de toute façon,
lorsque la population vieillit,
et de plus en plus,
il y aura de plus en plus de malades,
et qu’on ne peut pas changer
le fond génétique,
la stratégie la plus efficace,
à l’heure actuelle,
c’est d’essayer de prédire
l’apparition de ces pathologies
et, en les prédisant,
de pouvoir les traiter en amont
avant qu’elles ne se manifestent.
Est-ce qu’une telle prédiction
est possible ?
Autour de nous,
on en a des exemples
qui fonctionnent plus ou moins bien.
J’ai essayé madame Irma et sa boule
de cristal, ça n’a jamais marché.
Mais dans la réalité,
les prévisions météorologiques sont
un bon exemple de prédictions
qui fonctionnent à peu près bien.
Comment on fait ça ?
Il y a des super ordinateurs
qui contiennent des modèles mathématiques
de l’atmosphère terrestre,
modèles très compliqués qui ont été
construits au cours du temps
grâce à des données météo
qui ont été accumulées
et en sachant le temps
qu’il faisait à ce moment-là.
Ces modèles mathématiques sont nourris
chaque jour de données météorologiques -
la pression atmosphérique, la vitesse
du vent, la température, etc.
On utilise ces données
pour prédire le temps qu’il va faire
dans les jours qui suivent.
Imaginons maintenant qu’on puisse
faire la même chose chez l’homme,
qu’on soit capable
de mesurer des données biologiques
chez chaque individu au cours du temps
et qu’on dispose d’un modèle
qui nous permette
de prédire les trajectoires de
chaque individu au cours de sa vie.
Mettons ce modèle sous forme de carte.
S’il y a une chose dont
on est absolument sûr
c’est qu’on commence tous
de la même façon - c’est la conception -
et qu’on finit tous de la même façon -
c’est la mort.
Ce n’est pas parce que j’habite Marseille
que je considère que Paris, c’est la mort,
c’est juste que sur cette carte, toutes
les autoroutes convergent vers Paris.
Comme je vous l’ai dit, on a tous
un patrimoine génétique différent.
Ça veut dire quoi ?
Que notre point de départ sur la carte
va être différent
pour chacun d’entre nous.
Et l’idée c’est de pouvoir reconstruire
la trajectoire de chaque individu
jusqu’à la mort.
Maintenant, regardons
quelqu’un qui part de Marseille.
Pour aller à Paris,
il peut passer par Lyon
en fonction de ses expériences de vie.
Maintenant, considérons une autre personne
qui part aussi de Marseille,
qui va avoir d’autres expériences de vie.
Cette trajectoire va être différente.
Il va passer par Clermont-Ferrand
pour arriver à Paris.
Et enfin, un troisième individu
qui a un patrimoine génétique
complètement différent
va partir de Biarritz et va passer
par l’Ouest pour rejoindre Paris.
L’idée, c’est d’essayer
de reconstruire ce modèle
qui serait l’équivalent du modèle
de l’atmosphère terrestre,
pour les prévisions météo, chez l’homme,
reconstruire ces trajectoires.
Eh bien, c’est ce qui a lieu en ce moment
Dans de nombreux centres de
recherche de par le monde.
Des milliers de volontaires ont été
recrutés et sont suivis au cours du temps.
Et on va essayer de
construire leurs trajectoires
et d’établir cette carte.
Ça, c’est important,
parce que, statistiquement,
au cours du vieillissement, certains
vont développer des maladies du cerveau.
Et ça, ça va nous permettre
de visualiser ces maladies sur la carte.
On va pouvoir placer ainsi
où se trouve l’épilepsie,
où se trouve la maladie d'Alzheimer.
Et là, on aura franchi
une étape incroyable
pour prédire ces pathologies.
Pourquoi ?
Là, on aura construit le modèle
dont je vous parlais.
Et ensuite, quand on va prendre
d’autres individus
et suivre leurs paramètres biologiques,
on va suivre leur trajectoire.
Et quand on verra quelqu’un
qui part de Marseille,
qui passe par Lyon
et qui, après la bifurcation de Dijon,
reste sur la même autoroute,
on va pouvoir prédire qu’il va
développer une épilepsie à terme.
De la même façon, un autre individu
partant lui aussi de Marseille,
après Clermont-Ferrand
et la bifurcation pour Bourges,
on pourra prédire qu’il va développer
la maladie d’Alzheimer.
Et ça, ça nous permettra
de faire une médecine prédictive.
Et ça sera l’étape indispensable avant
de passer à la médecine préventive.
La médecine préventive n’en est
encore au stade des balbutiements.
C’est de la recherche fondamentale.
Mais vous comprenez très bien
comment ça peut se passer.
Mettons qu’on prédise
que quelqu’un soit sur une trajectoire
pour développer une épilepsie,
tout ce qu’il reste à faire,
c’est d’identifier un chemin
et de le pousser sur ce chemin pour qu’il
contourne la région où il y a l’épilepsie
afin qu'il ne la développe pas.
On n’en est pas encore là.
Vous pouvez me demander : « Est-ce
que c’est de la science-fiction ? »
Pas tout à fait.
Cette médecine 3P,
elle existe déjà, elle est
en train d’être développée
et notamment à l’Institut Neuroscience
des Systèmes à la Timone.
Et ça concerne l'épilepsie.
L’épilepsie, c’est le désordre
neurologique le plus fréquent
après la migraine.
Le problème, c’est que 30% des patients
ne répondent pas aux traitements
avec des médicaments.
Ça fait beaucoup, beaucoup de personnes.
Un espoir de guérison pour ces patients,
c’est la neurochirurgie.
Qu’est-ce que c’est ?
Ça consiste à enlever les régions du
cerveau qui sont responsables des crises,
quand c'est possible.
Et avec ça, on peut essayer
de guérir le patient.
Mais ce n'est pas facile d'identifier ces
régions qui sont responsables des crises.
Ce que l’on fait,
à Marseille, c’est la chose suivante :
lorsque les patients arrivent
dans le service clinique, ils vont subir
toute une batterie de tests.
Parmi ces tests, il y a une IRM
du cerveau qui est faite,
extrêmement détaillée.
Cette IRM du cerveau va permettre
de reconstruire dans l’ordinateur
le cerveau du patient.
Un avatar si vous voulez,
ou un cerveau virtuel.
Et ça, c’est de la médecine personnalisée
puisque chaque cerveau est unique.
Donc on va reconstruire dans l'ordinateur
le cerveau du patient.
Ensuite, il y a des modèles compliqués
avec de l’intelligence artificielle
qui permettent d’étudier
comment les crises sont générées
à l’intérieur de ce cerveau virtuel.
Et ça, ça permet de faire une prédiction,
de prédire quelles sont les régions
à enlever pour guérir le patient.
Cette information, cette prédiction,
est donnée à l’équipe clinique
avec toutes les autres données
qui sont accumulées sur ce patient
et l’équipe clinique décide ou non
de les utiliser pour la neurochirurgie.
C’est un essai clinique qui est
en cours et on saura à la fin
si la procédure de virtualisation augmente
le taux de succès de la neurochirurgie,
si on augmente le taux
de guérison des patients.
Ça, c’est actuellement en cours,
mais ça vous montre bien
un exemple concret de médecine 3P :
personnalisée puisque
chaque cerveau est unique,
prédictive, on prédit la zone qui est
responsable de l’apparition des crises,
préventive, et même plus que préventive,
puisqu’ici elle se veut curative.
Donc voici à quoi pourrait ressembler
la médecine du futur.
La médecine du futur
pourrait ressembler à ça.
On est capable de faire la cartographie
du génome de chaque individu.
Donc on sait quel est le point de départ.
On pourrait accumuler des données
tout au long de la vie d’un individu.
Des données biologiques,
ça peut être la fréquence cardiaque,
ça peut être le taux de cholestérol,
ça peut être l’activité du cerveau.
[Ça existe déjà.]
J'ai une montre connectée qui mesure
en permanence mon rythme cardiaque.
Votre téléphone peut mesurer
la qualité de votre sommeil.
Comme on a cette carte, comme on l’espère,
qui modélise les trajectoires
de chaque individu,
on va utiliser ces données pour
pouvoir prédire les trajectoires de chacun
et s’ils vont développer
à terme une maladie du cerveau.
Ça, ça fait appel évidemment au
Big data, à l’intelligence artificielle.
Il faudra résoudre des problèmes d’éthique
et de sécurité des données
bien avant de se lancer
dans ce genre d’entreprise.
Mais je ne vous ai pas encore parlé
du point le plus important.
Le point le plus important,
c’est le quatrième P.
Ce P-là, il veut dire « participatif ».
Cette médecine du futur ne verra le jour,
et ne sera couronnée de succès,
que si et seulement si l’individu
reste au centre des décisions.
C'est à lui de décider s'il veut fournir
ses données au cours de sa vie.
C'est à lui de décider ce qu'il fera
des prédictions qu'on lui fera.
C’est à lui de décider
de prendre un traitement préventif
pour empêcher
l’apparition des pathologies.
Autrement dit, l’individu doit
rester libre de ses décisions.
Ça, c’est un problème d’éthique qui se
conjugue au présent et pas dans le futur.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)